we mentioned the falcons earlier
in both
peter king's football morning in america
and albert brewer's monday morning
quarterback the idea is floated by the
writer not as a report but as an idea
that julio jones
could eventually be traded
post june 1. we've suggested that post
june 1 scenario as it relates to russell
wilson i keep thinking someone's going
to do it we see trades done in late
january they're unofficial until
mid-march why not have a trade in late
april that's official on june 2 when you
can dramatically reduce the cap charge
for the falcons it would be a 15 million
reduction in the cap charge for trading
julio jones so both king and breer are
suggesting this could happen
it it feels like to me someone in
atlanta is putting out the word yeah hey
say this could happen but don't couch it
as a report couch it is your own idea
that happens all the time right the fact
that two people are saying the same
thing that's either one hell of a
coincidence or somebody in atlanta is
saying hey go ahead and put this out
there just put it out there as your own
idea either way the idea is out there
julio jones could be traded but it
couldn't be for 2021 draft pick
compensation because it would
necessarily be a deal that becomes
effective as of june 2 2021. yeah i mean
i'm not surprised to hear this news
right i mean i think this is something
you you and i thought and we talked
about a lot towards the end of the
regular season last year that there
would be a chance that you know julio
jones would be on the trade block this
offseason and they might try to do
something with them i mean honestly i
thought maybe there was a chance they
might trade him during the season last
year i think that might have been the
time to actually do it you know right
now i look at it and just go
i i don't know mike i mean my my gut
feeling for the respect i have for julio
jones where i would say this is a guy
that's probably in the conversation for
the 10 greatest wide receivers of all
time i think he's in that combo he's
that special of a guy
where
i would would you want him at this point
of his career with that type of price
tag i'm not sure i would and i don't
mean that to be disrespectful i'm just
talking like feel football business here
i mean he's a guy that we know can
barely practice a lot of the weeks it's
always like well we're gonna see
saturday for julio we'll see how he
feels at the walk through and we'll
we'll we'll make the decision for
sunday's game then or it's wake up
sunday morning and we're going to hear
julio's going to work out before the
game right it's always that type of talk
so with that the type of money and then
of course like the play went downwards
last year i have a hard time thinking
there's going to be a huge market for a
guy like julio jones i don't know you
tell me is that crazy for me to think
that
no there's a couple of factors to
consider the salary isn't ridiculous in
comparison to the market you can't get
him
for the balance of his contract three
years left 15.3 this year 11.5 next year
11.5 the year after that those are not
ridiculous numbers the problem is he may
roll through the door saying i want more
money see he's gotta want to be traded
to you it's almost like trading for a
quarterback i think julio jones is
closer to that category of you better be
sure he wants to be there right i saw
one take the ravens peter suggested the
rave do you think julio jones is going
to accept the trade to the ravens hell
no hell no he may not show up if they
would do it yeah so
he's got to be on board with it and one
way to get him on board with it he may
want more money and the problem is guys
always have you know especially as they
get later in their career they remember
what they did they want to be paid for
what they've done they want they they
don't have
a great sense of reality
right right right they think they can
still do what they did five years no
doubt about it
and and that that complicates it as well
so uh
you know if there's any new deal to be
done he's got to be on board with it
even if they're trading the contract as
is you better make sure he's on board
with it or you're buying yourself a
problem
and uh
to your point yeah
is he still the guy that he was is he a
guy you can truly count on and this may
be why atlanta's trying to be a little
coy here trying to maybe stoke a market
when there may not be one there may not
be one maybe they'd love to be able to
trade him but there may not be a market
and when peter king suggests a second
round pick for julio jones hell that's
what they got for muhammad sanu right so
maybe it tells you the falcons uh
not quite fire sale when it comes to
julio jones but maybe they've realized
and maybe they've recognized that even
though they want to keep matt ryan
julio jones is the guy whose time has
come to move on just good luck finding
someone to take him i think that's going
to be the challenge someone to take on
that even though that contract isn't 22
23 24 million a year right most of the
money's already been paid out that's
still a lot to pay to one guy
who uh is far closer to the end in the
beginning yeah definitely i mean who had
770 yards last year and was banged up
and not the number one receiver on his
own team right so
i'm you know it does it sounds crazy to
say it but i mean i think a second
rounder is probably they'd probably go
okay we we'd take that
you know i don't know if anybody for
that number we're talking about even
though like you said it's not like a
huge number for what the market is right
now
i don't know to me it'd be one of those
things where it jumps out to me mike
like where
hey maybe he's you know on the market
right now right a little bit like hey
yeah we're but but i i think it's going
to be more of one of those things where
it's going to be
it's going to have to take a team that
looks at themselves as like a super bowl
contender right and they get into
training camp and they realize ooh
we need one more person and i think we
can win the super bowl like maybe it's
the green bay packers maybe some like a
team like that you know what i'm saying
i think it's that type of team that type
of situation that's going to trade for
julio like because to your point earlier
it's not going to be some team that's
like on the up and coming right and it's
like oh yeah we want an old veteran
receiver and now we might have to pay
him more money with a contract extension
as we're rebuilding our team that makes
no sense to me would have to be a team
that is legit like we're we're one guy
away we need one playmaker and maybe
that does happen as we get closer to
training camp or go throughout training
camp
he became a problem for the falcons
three years ago right and we have
drawn the line to the matt ryan most
recent contract that pays him 30 million
a year
at the time julio jones was making 15
million a year
easy to say wait a minute wait a minute
that guy isn't worth twice as much as me
to this team that guy's who he is in
part because of me but also at the same
time
that same time period when there was you
know this vague talk is he going to hold
out is he not going to hold out
i remember hearing
that
julio jones was kind of changing because
he's he was spending time with a lot of
really really rich people and if you're
a football player there's only one way
to get really really really rich and
that's to maximize your football
earnings period and that's why he drew
the line in the sand got the 22 million
dollar contract and i think he's been
kind of a headache behind the scenes for
the falcons the past few years and i'm
saying all this
because number one i'm not sure i've
ever said it before but i've known it
for three years but number two
i'm going to throw a dart here yeah i'm
not go i'm not going to quite close my
eyes but i am going to throw a dart it
may hit the board it may not hit the
board here's my prediction okay if they
don't if they don't trade him
they're going to cut him june 2.
that's my prediction
because even though it'll cost them
money right under the cap they're going
to save 15 million yeah in a year where
the caps down you got to look at you say
a guy played nine games last year right
and maybe they're thinking some days he
didn't go when we think maybe he could
have gone maybe they're thinking that
and you know what we we clear up 15
million in cash
and cap space by moving on yeah we're
going to take a cap charge yeah but it's
not nearly the cap charge we would have
taken we're going to come out of it
ahead of the game net and i think the
key is
if at four
they take
a kyle pitts
or jamar chase right
that that's the next step down that
trail okay they'll try to trade him
after that if they don't find any takers
if they can't work it out i think june 2
it's thanks for the memories julio jones
that's when we see on social media thank
you julio jones from the atlanta falcons
on the day there tell him to pack up his
stuff and move on it i mean it's not a
crazy thought i mean i'm i'm i don't i
mean there's there's logic there there's
no doubt and yeah i mean he could be
expendable because of kind of like what
you're saying i mean if you made me bet
money i'd bet atlanta takes kyle pitts
from florida pick number four only thing
i would say where i'm just a little
tentative to buy on to what you said
because it makes a lot of sense
it's just though the fact that like this
is arthur smith's first year he's an
offensive guy
i would think he's gonna want
a julio there just so his offense looks
special to get off on the right
propaganda note in atlanta so everybody
can be like hey look it was a good hire
look at this offense it was fun i don't
know but it's an interesting thought
nonetheless you're right mike i mean for
this year for what he is right now the
the issues with the body you know the
salary cap issues with the league like
you said it's it's not a crazy thought i
hear you there
you draft pits fourth overall that goes
a long way towards
replacing julio jones and then you take
one of these other receivers round three
round four there's so you know we keep
hearing there is so many there is and
you got calvin ridley so i just think
that if arthur smith really does want to
give get off on the right note and
there's a lot of stuff that we don't
know about this background relationship
between jones and the falcons and maybe
arthur blank and rich mckay have gotten
a little exasperated with him
i i think just the fact that we're
starting draft week
with
the two primary
monday morning news columns peter king's
football morning in america and si's
monday morning quarterback which peter
started all those years ago both with
the same damn thing yeah not a report
just a suggestion
don't don't be surprised it tells me
that that mckay has been sent out to lay
the foundation to try to get a trade for
julio jones and they've mapped it out
they've played it out if they can't pull
it off i think june 2 it's going to be
see you later julio yeah maybe they'll
trade him maybe they'll trade him but
but you know when you said who's going
to want to take on that contract
that's when it occurred to me well if
they can't trade them why would they
want to keep that contract if no one
wants to take it on yeah no i mean
listen it's certainly a good thought the
only thing i can think of you know again
is
he does have talent he's still explosive
as hell that's where i think maybe they
want to keep them one more year
not take the dead cap hit get arthur
smith's career going in the right
direction here
and go that way you know so i don't know
either way
i'm not shocked to hear that he's on the
trading block i'm really not i don't
think there's going to be a huge market
for him you know because of all the
issues we've talked about be something
to watch here though it really would be
i don't think this is a trade that goes
down this week or anything during trade
you know the draft weekend i think this
is one of those where teams get to otas
they start to evaluate their team a
little bit and start to go okay wait we
do have a real need for a difference
making receiver maybe that's when we
start to hear something you know a
little more concrete with this
but now is the perfect time yeah to
throw that idea
out into the stream
and you know it's like it's like it's
like fishing
that this is the cast by the falcons and
they're just gonna sit there and they're
gonna wait to see if the pole starts to
start to you know that feeling when you
see that pulse starting to jiggle and
you know you got something on the line
all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports